hey it's pete i'm in shanghai china
today and i'm at a very cool space
called hackerspace we're geeks get
together and play with various
technology including a lot of robotics
related stuff and today I have the
pleasure of talking to Ricky and Ricky's
the founder of a company called DF robot
and he's going to tell us a little bit
about what they're up to in terms of
making her greenock its which is quite
cool actually and so we're really happy
to be here thanks for coming thank you
so Ricky first tell me a little bit
about DF robot and the high level or
what you guys do right actually dear
crow which is actually start from 2007
and we are probably the first company to
introduce a torino in China and then we
form the official company in 2008
started building adrenal kit and robots
and the main target is for education and
the harvest side the very beginning and
then we ask start growing and the target
more industry level for customers great
so just to set the stage for all the
geeks out there who might not know what
ardrey know is I'm tell us a little bit
about what's cool about Audrey know and
what the big deal is and I think Audrina
is the open source hardware as in
everybody knows and its first design for
interactive work so the main purpose of
adrenal is to bridge the gap for
engineer for software developer and the
day actual physical world so it's the
the link between software and actual
work so a drink is an easy-to-use board
which a software programmer kid just
simple click view attempts and burn the
programs into the board
and then you have the capability to
control the actual sensors to read data
from sensors to control the a curator
such as the Moto's and with the Moto's
you can do a lot of things it's just
based our imaginations cool you have a
drain on board here I think this is one
of your kids and you just show us
briefly what what the hardware looks
like yeah so so this is the standard
Audrina board and you can see it's very
simple and elegant and beautiful and
here's this as the our product for the
week all it's our expansion shield so
what this Dewey is too it's actually
expand the capability of our dry nose so
you can see it's just simply stuck on
and with this body actually you can see
there's a lot of pain out which expanded
the pains for adrenals and also you have
the wireless communication socket which
you keep the adrenal a wireless
communication or ability such as the XP
modules which is very popular in the
industry also this gives you ice 2 3 4 a
5 communication ports as well so with
this body it's you came very easy to
expand the capability of adrenal and
also it's designed for some kids like
this we got this visit i draw a stick
module right sir so with this module you
can do a lot of gaming or
motion controls our face but instead
adrenals it's not that easy you needed
to hardwire a lot of cables to this
module but with this I'll expansion sure
where you need to do it just plug on ok
I'll go write some code job done it's
that kind of easy that's great so talk
to me a little bit about the the
software that you use to control these
devices is that is that something very
obscure or obtuse or is that how does
that work when you want to talk to an
adrenal device with software oh
basically we use in standard Arduino IDE
it's derived from the processing
language it's basically scrabble Java
kind style programming format so i think
most of all programmers of the program
have blacks very easily maybe an hour or
two now and waiting to do is just a
standard programming IDE writing type
codes and the we do is just and compile
and float and job done okay interesting
and now the I'd renal platform is open
source I guess I feel like I know what
that means when it comes down to open
source software but what does open
source hardware what what does that mean
open source conway is too they they just
give you all details about hardware such
as disk mattox to the design file
probably the layout file the firmware
also the bo em which a buell material so
with this for files actually can easy to
put this to a factory and they can paste
they can manufacture products based on
this vote I feel for open source
hardware which means you can very easy
to copy and we reproduce the product so
one of these boards in adrenal board
costs around what twenty dollars or so
yeah some kinda so so if this board
costs twenty dollars and you don't want
to spend twenty dollars for every piece
of product that you deliver to a
customer what you're saying is you're
able to send the spec send this to a
factory work me mass-produce for much
cheaper and I think the most today the
application so far is say using a dream
to do a rapid prototyping and the for
mature product they will design a new /
board may be based on Draenor maybe not
for that purpose you can save a lot of
costs because all the vowels in open so
you can very easy to modify and
reproduce the product see that's great
um so it's basically for those of us who
do startups and understand the whole
concept of rapid iteration Arduino
allows you to do quicker cycles with
hardware that is that right that's
correct yeah so when it comes down to
real world products and applications is
is our drainage of something for geeks
who like robots or is there some some
real-world applications that you've seen
in the market that are that are
interesting
if you're interesting of you know I
drano about it you know how drain oil is
applied in various kind of works such as
interactive art education robotics even
home automation as well but that's the
past from last year we have several
customers actually come to us looking
for a code development for industrial
product the recent all finished product
is called a stomach pro product which
using our industry stomach stomach probe
yes okay so they actually have asked
other companies are traditional
companies using the prsa or other
microcontroller to detail to the
development and they figure out the cost
and the
developed time yes it's not
a good thing uh-huh and such as for a
standard one is like 12 month and for us
I mean we saved time to one month we
finish the project in a month and then
we save the cost about the one of the 50
mm so which is a great team so so
there's arguably ways to put real
products in the market based on our
greenough technology that already
supports certain kinds of standards
standards compliance yes that's right
because adrenal head itself has already
passed all the tests so that the design
is immature and the reliable and that
the second case is we recently working
with account per day which trying to
design a sec away style transport Asia
tools and they designed for a Walmart
actually and they use an adrenal as the
main controller
and that they sell 5,000 in a year but
that project lisandro that's amazing
thing well I find it fascinating as an
entrepreneur and a geek myself that the
Arduino platform allows me to create
hardware based solutions and then send
them off for manufacturing and
potentially even as a as a low capital
style lean start-up operation produce a
real world useful hardware based
solution that's fascinating yeah that's
that's the biggest part of our training
let's desp'rate to a dream I mean using
our drain them you can produce a lot of
end application not today you have
product application but we think Audrina
is in the industry level is just too in
the middle it's giving you the
capability to rapid prototyping to the
research but it's not used the water in
order right so do you think if I come up
with a really cool application a
hardware based application solution that
foxconn want my business yeah if you
have setka idea you can drain 02 to do
protect me and manufacture yeah that's
great very cool